it literally could chopped your head off
hey look how look how Bart's butt
munches up these shorts Brother come
[Music]
on imagine all right you're a pretty
decent looking white chick named Kenzie
hunt 20 years old right and then you go
on a [__] nice little vacation this
sounds like a nightmare girls trip to
South Carolina dude South Carolina oh
I'm a southern girl yeah that's
wholesome that's wholesome right but who
goes to South Carolina for a trip what's
that Myrtle Beach you go there you go
there Monday night because Tuesday
morning you're going you're going
boating what's boating you just drink
alcoh is that a white guy thing only you
guys don't go boating n we don't do oh
that's the [__] sweater like this
kind of [__] right with the boat is it
the is it the spring break woo no way
you guys are that Asian like The Classy
like type chicks no way you're that
Asian bro no we're not we're not going
on like a [__] sailboat yeah
boing [__] Mario spar's or whatever
the [__] no bro you grabbing one with
like these speakers on it we're playing
some like maybe we're playing some
Leonard skinnard cuz we're in South
Carolina but but it's a it's some engine
we got some brusis BR in a cooler no
dude that's Lake life [__] that's
[__] Mountain de BR yeah that's where
I grew up well I think Arizona people
would know what that is I'm talking
about South Carolina but we're not from
there right we're vacation
Carina sweater I think that's East Coast
Tommy Hill I've been to I've been to
Sumter South Carolina it [__] sucks
really sucks oh and they do this thing
called crabbing yeah like they hang out
at a dock and they wait for the tide to
come in and then they just like stick
little like um not really fishing poles
but like strings in there pull crabs out
and kill them on the spot that sounds
fun as [__] they do some of that NorCal
like the Santa Cruz is yeah but NorCal
got dungeoness and dungeoness is one of
the best kind of we are officially
derailing we're back in South Carolina
we're going boating get got
Kenzie
probably you're gross dude funny you're
going out tubing that's still legal
tubing see I yeah Mountain too
broo going out with one of your friends
husbands and all of his friends even
though you don't know a bunch of them
you go out tubing and you're on the tube
with another chick and then one of the
guys is driving that and you don't know
this guy you don't you never need to
know M okay trust all Humanity one of
the girls falls off and he goes and
picks her up but when he goes to pick
her up he makes really sharp U-turn oh
no and he cut and he kills her yeah I
don't like this no no there's no death
involved she survived just even chopped
her up okay yeah he comes at her head on
she's still laying on the tube your
imagine so you're laying on you guys
ever done any of this I've been tubing
like often you're have to do with
anything I know what it feels like with
a boat flying at you is scary as [__]
you can empathize we're adding emotional
dram I'm scared to these you see those
propellers bro and they're going they're
literally just what happens to Port
Kenzie you can see it you can see it is
it tubing when you're in in a tube and
they have the rope and then you're just
like but yeah you got to know someone
that knows how to drive a boat been
doing it bro you're sit situational
awareness yeah you got to shut off the
engine and swim to it I've been on a
tube on a lake but no boat was pulling
me it was very slow that's floating no
I've yeah I've been when they're fly
Floy this is like I'm watching a movie
with my mom and she's explaining to me
what's happening while I'm already
watching the [__]
movie dude these guys obviously never
been on a boat you're laying there on
the going to let us know what's up and
then you get hit head first all right
you get sucked under the boat yeah yeah
out yes there's a propeller and the
propeller starts winding you up no okay
like a blender bro that's final
destination the Rope gets caught on your
neck there's Whiplash involved you black
out for a second and then next thing you
know you're getting pulled back up by
your friends you definitely are bleeding
all over the place you got no legs you
got no butt what it took her butt that's
not bad butt off of all things that's it
that's not bad she can't walk forward
dude she has no butt butt off oh
true that's that's what you're Hing
you're hinging muscle you can't you
can't you bro you got no butt muscle
wait you got to be in a wheelchair can
you do the sence can you show people how
the butt works in your forward walking
motion get them back with squats so
these are your hips but think about the
recovery dude you're F flees your hips
it literally could chopped your head off
hey look how look how Bart's butt
munches up these shorts Brother come on
a hungry careful boy merch available now
he's a hungry boy I think that was bar
Bri Gade merch but yes oh this is F boys
nice nice
nice well luckily they were able to rush
into the hospital after calling the cops
and they kind of they kind of put her
butt back together wait they found the
other parts of the butt no it was like
it was more like it wasn't like it
wasn't like slic and then meat was fully
off it was more like slice all open [__]
so they kind of had to like oh it was
flopping yeah they kind of had to like
have sliced up just spiraled yeah cuz
you know if the butt was in one piece
and it landed on a boat wanted the do
would have been like yeah yeah you seen
the PornHub like twerk
aons like PornHub like makes like a dude
toy and it's basically just a butt with
a hole oh those the butt toys I've seen
the toy but I haven't seen the twerk
ofon well I think it moves I think it's
got a battery in there oh wow it's like
a flashlight they send me that link
flashlight but the whole I don't know my
friend told
me yeah I don't know my friend has one I
don't know yeah saw it on the internet
Tik Tok I don't want to see [__] looking
like she's in good spirits what is she
doing the wo she's in the yeah she's in
the hospital she was explaining the
situation over the Tik toks she was huh
yeah you got to chase the clout when you
get your ass chopped off you do though I
feel like you deserve
it it's not your fault it's a story to
tell yeah can she walk though I don't
want to see anything graphic bro I I
can't see butts CH I don't think she's
putting that on Tik Tok then she doesn't
want it that bad she doesn't want she
don't want she don't want to go viral I
guess she don't want it I hope she can
walk does anybody G gone tubing I'm not
sing floating I'm saying tubing I've
been tubing before no you're a tuber not
on a rope what do you call it when it's
a uh like a surfboard but you're being
pulled on a rope so that's wake boarding
or or there's wake surfing what's the
difference wake boarding you're holding
the Rope the whole time you're hauling
ass uh surfboarding you're you use the
rope to start then you'll go and you're
literally surfing you're kind of going
slow that boat is slow enough just to
create a constant wave so you don't need
the rope and you can just keep riding
the wave constantly probably going
pretty slow there wakeboarding you might
you're going pretty fast the fastest is
skiing cuz skiing they're not really
riding a wake they're just hauling ass
you're going like 40 some people put
their feet in the water yeah people can
go no oh that's what Jackie Chan did
right that's just real and then when
they hit the water they [__] I had
buddies i t into that we had like yeah
Lake life up there that [__] sounds fun
though tubing's fun there is there a
lake in Sacramento we got fome Lake and
then Lake Tahoe and then Doner Lake
those are the three they're all within
an hour what like the big tube that it's
more like a raft and like four people
can sit on boats pulling yeah we've done
all that [__] that's still tubing yeah
yeah I've done that that SS cool and
[__] ate [__] yeah but it doesn't
hurt that bad no not too bad as long as
the dude's not driving over your ass
that's [__] crazy that's crazy that's
that's irresponsible a lot of the boats
do like uh the newer ones will do like a
Mid Engine boat sometimes and so the
propeller is dead middle of the boat so
it's much less likely to get chopped off
oh rather that it be cuz you can jump
off the back yeah and then it's like
safe yeah so we've like jumped off the
back of a boat and that's cool you're
[__] tough X Games brother
I like when they put a cage around it
then I feel a little better sharks no no
around the propeller yeah oh yeah yeah
well you would think that would be a
no-brainer right yeah that's not
standard practice it isn't maybe it
slows it down or something yeah I'm sure
there's something but it seems like a
no-brainer there should be a guard yeah
something just something in the way I
saw this other clip of this dude who was
trying to hang off the back of the boat
and the the the propeller was sucking
the the water down this way but he was
able to hold on he's a pretty fit buff
dude and he's holding on and and then
you just [__] see him kind of get hit
and then his buddies pull him up but
when they pull him up he's missing the
leg as he comes up I can't do that bro
people like to do dumb [__] man dude one
of the only guys who survived the
Titanic when like you know like when the
people went in the water right not many
people survived having been in the water
the people who mostly survived were
already in life boats one of too cold
yeah it was too cold so one of the guys
who actually survived being in the water
he says that while the Titanic was
vertical he was like he jumped he Dove
and barely missed the propeller which is
crazy to even visualize prob the size of
this room yeah yeah but that's that was
like something that he said he
viscerally remembers is barely missing
the propeller was the
propeller according to the movie it
wasn't at that point didn't they just
have the anniversary right that's why
they named the submarine yeah around it
and then they had the anniversary cuz I
did see a clip where they showed like a
bunch of like I guess they were probably
80 90 years old but they're like the
survivors I didn't know people survived
oh yeah today they're still alive yeah
they're like 90 or 100 or some [__]
there's like one dude or two dudes that
I think we're still alive when did it
happen 1940s 1912 or some [__] I was
going to say yeah or did it happen 1997
I don't think it
happened 97 the movie yeah I thought it
was 97 Leonardo but that's not when it's
happened no no no no yeah 19 early early
19 sounds right dressed off it was a
couple years before that 1912 April 1912
12 maiden voyage and out of service
April 15th yeah so if they were youngish
they could be alive is if they were like
that's that's right now yeah I swear uh
we should look it up but I I think you
just watched videos yeah you watched
videos of survivors but they're dead now
yeah it might have been like A9 have
been the 50 yeah it might have be the '
90s cuz it was definitely in color cuz
during the time the movie Titanic came
out it was believable that old [__] was
still alive Rose Dawson yep dude
listening to these old people talk to
I'm like dang people used to be really
smart why oh cuz they're so El Quinton
like remembering the night and
remembering everything and like now the
way that even I talk I'm like damn I
sound dumb dude my aun rest in peace the
way she said program is program program
that's that's pretty classic and I'm
like the way that they used to
speak I thought she just had a Japanese
accent but it was actually just English
just smart people yeah smart English old
school English that's true if you if you
like hear like letters Like Love Letters
being read at that time of people that
didn't that didn't even go to college
just out of high school it's yeah it's
so
eloquent now we have people going to
college and [__] writing like retards
to each other but you think that's just
a time thing I text to my wife last
night I texted my wife last night send
but send but that's nice but I mean what
else do you need to know there's some
sort of poetry in there if you really
think about it though big words before
it was like my dear
Elanor every time I wish upon your bosom
to caress my dud pelvic my heart teer
Pats once we started typing RB and G2G
that was kind of our fault that was the
[__] decline I spelled but by the way
BTT that's how [__] dumb
am snd d space
BTT you didn't use a peach Emoji no all
right that would have been
faster I got it
[Music]
though